in the lobby a financial piece Plaza is
Ty and Nicky hey guys how are you
I'm tired this is Nikki and we're the
Burien I'm guessing you're here to do a
debt free scream without a time we got
started in 2010 after I did our taxes a
lot coming in apparently a lot going out
couldn't tell you where I just felt like
something something had to change we
were able to get Dave Ramsey's book from
pastor Randy I read that book in about
three days and I said we gotta try this
she was like no and I basically told him
I was not on board I didn't want to do
it I didn't believe it I was showing her
the stories I run over and look at this
story they paid off all this money they
can do it we can we had them so much
trouble leading up to that with almost
losing this house and just being flooded
with dead I'm going to bed at night
sleeping but he's not and I knew that we
had to do something because it was
weighing on him could you imagine what
it would be like this debt didn't exist
what if we could take a trip what if we
could go on vacations and not have to
worry about money let's just try it I
said okay those first few months were
rough we were pulling back the reins on
eating out going do things that we would
normally just find a way to go and do we
said no when we started this process
Paris was enrolled in a private school
some of the change that we decided to
make was to pull her out of private
school as a cost savings and forced me
to take a more active role it's about me
and relying upon my private institution
to do that for me so while it was a
tough decision it was the right decision
well when we started doing the budget to
be able to tell your money what to do
and not allow other things to tell you
what to do that was more powerful to me
than anything you know there's great
benefit in knowledge we were just
ignorant to where the money was going
well our daughters have been well
involved in this process so I kept
asking if
we were definitely yet all the work I've
seen them do I'm pretty sure I don't
want to do that and what we're hoping
that they're learning is you know when I
become an adult and when I'm of age and
have my own family I don't have to have
dick in 2001 we were sitting back
watching the Super Bowl a BMW commercial
came on about a new SUV they were
launching in 2001 called the x5 that
very week we went down and we bought the
x5 to go along with it we bought her a
3-series at the same time riding out of
the car dealership with over $100,000 in
cars has to be without question the
stupidest thing I did I've just watched
him grow so much over the last few years
and I just have complete trust that
every decision he makes whether I give
input or not I know that it's for the
good of our family we learned how to
budget together we learned how to manage
money together you know going through
the last three plus years and this walk
just through baby step two has redefined
how I look at my my legacy or our family
legacy
the barians we are in a place where we
can give we can love and and we can
truly be ministers of the gospel without
the constraint of the pressure of it
that is an amazing freedom as an amazing
blessing and I praise God for it every
day
you